[Música]
después de 40 años de silencio el grupo
abba embarca a sus fans hacia nuevos
horizontes
[Aplausos]
los suecos agnetha björn venían y fritz
no habían lanzado una nueva canción
desde su separación de 1982
pero a medianoche de este viernes el
mítico cuarteto ha develado su nuevo
álbum guayas una consagración para estos
fans incondicionales reunidos para
escuchar juntos los diez nuevos hits de
sus ídolos
y lo soñamos durante muchos años y nunca
hubiéramos creído que sería posible
es verdaderamente formidable para mí
poder vivir esto porque yo nací 11 años
después de su separación
[Música]
haba vendió al menos 160 millones de
álbumes en el mundo entero y en los años
70 el grupo conquistó el planeta con
éxitos inolvidables y traje esquís
hoy con entre 71 y 76 años las estrellas
preparan una nueva gira una serie de
conciertos pero no en carne y hueso sino
con avatares en forma de hologramas que
subirán a escena en su lugar y los
representarán con su apariencia de
después de una preparación de años el
proyecto tiene la intención de reiniciar
la máquina va a toda velocidad
[Música]